Comment éteindre une bougie sans souffler dessus ?
Pour allumer une bougie, nous savons que nous
avons besoin d'un combustible, la cire de la
bougie et d'une source d'énergie. La flamme du
briquet ou de l'allumette. Seulement nous sommes
passés à côté d'un troisième élément. Est-ce que
tu le connais ? Sinon l'expérience d'aujourd'hui
va permettre de le découvrir. Pour cela,
je vais avoir besoin d'un petit verre, d'un verre
un peu plus grand même si moi j'ai un erlenmeyer.
Et de deux bougies. On va d'abord allumer les
deux bougies avec un briquet ou une allumette.
Puis on va placer en même temps
les deux bougies sous les verres.
Et on va attendre pour voir ce qui se passe.
Voilà, on voit que la bougie sous le petit verre
s'est éteinte assez rapidement alors
que celle sous le grand verre continue
de brûler. On va attendre un petit
peu jusqu'à ce qu' elle s'éteigne.
C'est maintenant chose faite on voit que la bougie
présente dans le grand verre brûle plus longtemps
que celle dans le petit verre c'est à cause denotre troisième élément, l'oxygène.
Une flamme, c'est le résultat d'une réaction chimique entre lecombustible, la cire et un comburant, l'oxygène.
Cette réaction chimique produit du dioxydede carbone, le fameux CO2. Ce CO2 finira par
étouffer la flamme lorsqu'il l'entourera
complètement. Car elle n'aura plus d'accèsà l'oxygène.
Plus rapidement dans le petitverre que dans le grand.
Les trois éléments essentiels pour le feu sont : le combustible :
la cire, le comburant : l'oxygène et l'énergie
c'est ce qu'on appelle le triangle du feu. Pouréteindre des incendies les pompiers suppriment l'un
de ces trois éléments. Pour supprimer l'accèsà l'oxygène ils ont plusieurs outils à leur
disposition. Des extincteurs qui permettent deremplacer l'oxygène par du dioxyde de carbone
dont ils sont remplis et des petits jets degouttelettes d'eau sur le feu qui se transforment
en vapeur d'eau. Cette vapeur va prendre laplace de l'oxygène autour de l'incendie.
Je t'invite à refaire l'expérience chez toi avec unadulte, le feu ça brûle ! Merci d'avoir regardé
cet épisode et je te donne rendez-vous la semaineprochaine pour répondre à une nouvelle question.